this week on brian ross investigates
before the george floyd case the
minneapolis police department
already had a record involving violent
arrests of people of color
like this woman arrested for simply
jaywalking
these stupid games against prizes that's
what happened
we'll hear from the former minneapolis
police chief forced to resign herself
four years ago chief has resigned
there has been certainly i believe
systemic racism and frankly systemic
inequalities
in every government institution
including police departments including
your
former police department i would include
my my i
you know we're not we're not unlike
other departments
plus the derek chauvin trial has
highlighted the role
of police body cameras but a study in
the neighboring state of iowa discovered
police in many states often refused to
make videos public
like this one i'll kill you drop the gun
drop the gun
without a huge legal battle they may
decline to release it in cases when
they're not sure how they're going to
look
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of meteorite
what you're saying is right how does
that not pay to play that's a fake
narrative
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin with week two of the
derek chauvin trial
we're about to hear from the former
minneapolis police department about the
fact
that it's been notoriously difficult to
prosecute police officers
especially when other officers close
ranks behind them
the so-called blue line but that hasn't
happened in the derrick chauvin case
his supervisory sergeant testified
against him the senior member of the
force said what he did
was totally unnecessary and then this
week the police chief himself testified
rhonda
that's right minneapolis police chief
madario arredondo
took the stand to say the sanctity of
life was the vital consideration in any
use of force situation
it was just four years ago that his
predecessor chief jenae harto
was forced to resign after the death of
another minneapolis citizen at the hands
of police brian
we're joined now by former minneapolis
police chief janae harteau ms harteau
thank you so much for joining us
thanks for having me brian as you watch
this trial unfold in your old city
what is your takeaway well it's really
it's personally challenging to watch the
minneapolis police department
being seen in this light knowing all the
great work that was done by the men and
women during the 31 years that i was
there
i mean it's difficult for any police
department to see that one of your
colleagues
is now standing trial for really a
horrific death
at the hands of a police officer so it
is it is kind of hard to watch
and all too familiar for the former
chief we do begin with breaking news the
minneapolis police chief has just
resigned in the wake of a police
shooting
the mayor asked chief jenae harteau to
resign four years ago
after a woman who had called to report a
crime was shot
dead by an officer muhammad noor later
convicted and sentenced
to 12 years in prison the resignation of
minneapolis police chief jenae harteau
coming as no surprise
to many in minneapolis's fulton
neighborhood but for others who have
long been critical of chief harteau
it was a moment worth celebrating we had
a great announcement today chief harto
has resigned
[Applause]
as you look back at your term as chief
of the department are there any
failures you recognize that you think
something you could have done better
that
would have perhaps prevented this i'm
constantly looking at things
can i you know is there anything i could
have done
personally to prevent this i don't know
the answer to that
former chief hartel told me she never
knew derek chovin
but that she was repulsed by what she
saw on the videos played in court
yeah i was just sickened and thought to
myself and actually spoke out loud
i can't believe i'm gonna watch a guy
die on tv
at the hands of a minneapolis police
officer i mean it's just something that
you don't see
thankfully but something that should
have never happened
there was a settlement with the family
of a man by the name of david smith that
required the police department to give
training about this
needed neck restraint including showing
apparently uh
nypd video about the dangers of keeping
the person
in a prone position too long was that
enough clearly
they didn't reach derrick shovel well
everybody in the department's received
proper training and and the actions of
officer shelvin in this state were
is not the type of force that we train
um and this is not acceptable for us and
even if it had been
it didn't stop in time either so use of
force is second by seven
minute by minute if something's uh you
know acceptable at the time does it mean
it is
um in the next minute we've seen part of
his personnel record showing a number of
complaints alleging brutality
yet he continued on the force even at
one point received a medal of valor how
did that happen
well i can't speak specifically to um
officer chauvin but i can say
unfortunately we have systems that don't
work effectively
for each individual we continue to make
more improvements with our use of force
policies
we do have challenges with past practice
we look at
certainly just individual cases at the
time and they don't necessarily
aggregate and we don't have effective
early warning systems
for most police departments to really
get things while they're small
address them and make sure they don't
become larger the former chief says her
efforts to reform her department
were often frustrated by the police
union
yeah it was beyond frustrating i had
terminated officers it would be grieved
you know even lower levels of discipline
would be grieved by the unions
arbitrators over 50 60 percent of the
time would overturn
my decision to terminate an officer
one time i terminated an officer and
instead of
the termination holding the arbitrator
thought
two weeks off without pay was sufficient
this guy
actually the officer has soon been since
been uh
terminated because he continued to do
the things that i had
saw him do and tried to hold him
accountable to so it
it does present challenges but community
activists also say as seen in so many
disturbing
police body cam videos there is a
cultural racism at play from myself as a
black male growing up in minneapolis
i've been pulled over jogging i've been
pulled over biking
i've been pulled over walking i've been
pulled over
simply for being black so don't get it
twisted when you when i say what the
movement
was it was simply for being black a
woman
violently arrested for jaywalking
these stupid games get stupid prizes
that's what happened
a woman violently arrested on a traffic
stop
can you turn your car off please
step out of the vehicle right now
all by officers not named derrick short
there's been the argument that derek
shoving was just one of the few bad
apples but is there a larger cultural
issue
with your former department is there a
lack of respect for
people of color in the making arrests
and dealing with them
you know 99 of the men and women
go to work every day and do a fabulous
job but there has been
certainly i believe uh systemic racism
and frankly systemic inequalities
in every government institution
including police departments
including your former police department
i would include my
my you know we're not we're not unlike
other departments
but you would agree there is a issue of
systemic racism
inside your former police department
inside the minneapolis police department
i would say there's systemic
inequalities across the board
from gender to race uh to all of it i
once fought my own department in the
mid-90s
i was in the middle of a hostile work
environment very public
and almost left my job and it's very
unique
uh to have someone to have gone through
that to want then
lead the department so i i talk a lot
about how i led the department i once
had to fight
uh but minneapolis isn't unlike other
cities uh we're not unique in that way
and so uh that's why there's outcries
across the country
this has been built over decades
hundreds
you know minneapolis police department
150 years old
have you thought about finally what
would be a just outcome
in this trial
i i really think that the outcome
speaks for itself i i think we all know
what what should happen
and i would expect that to happen all
right
chief thank you so much for being with
us here appreciate it very much
thank you for having me
coming up next those police body cam
videos so important in the derek chauvin
trial
but in many states police fight hard to
keep them from becoming
public you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
the trial of derek shoven has
underscored the role and the importance
of police body cam
videos both prosecution and defense have
used them to score points
but as we're about to see in many states
around the country
there are efforts by police to fight
hard to keep them from becoming public
rhonda
that's right and in the state right
below minnesota in iowa
50 reporters joined a consortium 30
newspapers
and they've discovered that police don't
often want to make public anything that
puts them in a bad light
we're joined now by aaron jordan an
investigative reporter at the cedar
rapids gazette who helped to coordinate
this uh impressive and ambitious program
so in iowa as in other states it's not
automatic that those videos become
public
right you know i think our law is a
little bit outdated in terms of how it
deals with police video
and we're not just talking about body
camera there's all sorts of cameras
there's
pistol mounted cameras cameras that go
on tasers things like that as well
the iowa project highlighted what
happened in three cases where people
died
including this one involving a woman
named autumn steele
hey hey hey stop it
get your dog
autumn steel was a 34 year old mom
having a domestic situation that had
moved out to her front lawn
the police had been called her husband
was there as long as one
along with one of her children the
police officer that responded
there was a dog barking he kind of
slipped in the snow he accidentally
shot autumn steel fatally and then what
happened to the video
well the police department there did not
want to turn over the complete video
they provided a very short snippet that
didn't show kind of what what happened
immediately afterwards so we didn't know
how the officer responded and other
things
and that full video was not made public
until
the family filed a wrongful death
lawsuit
so they actually had to go to court
essentially file the suit
right and then the media got the video
through
the defense attorney the earth through
the plaintiff's attorney
reporters found the same sort of
resistance involving this video
showing the aftermath of a police chase
in central iowa
involving a man named isaiah hayes as
isaiah hayes was exiting the vehicle and
kind of running
um he was shot by officers i'll kill you
drop the gun drop the gun
[Music]
and what happened to the video this
video
was was had to the iowa public or the
iowa freedom of information council
had to work to get this video and they
did eventually get a copy of that video
but not easily
and how about drew edwards drew edwards
was a young man
uh 22 years old uh again kind of a
domestic situation
uh some friends of his had asked him to
leave their residence
and he wasn't really doing so so
willingly uh police tried to get him to
come in uh to the station he wouldn't
they ended up tasing him please stop
put your hand behind your back
and that he had a medical condition that
that stun gun kind of led to his death
eventually
the reporters in iowa found as in this
case police often cite privacy of the
suspect
as a reason to not release the video
yeah and you know in fact in the edwards
case edwards family themselves wanted
the video
so the idea that there would be some
question of uh mr edwards privacy
when his family wanted it is you know is
very um hard to take as we've seen in
the derek's chauvin trial the police
videos are so important
for both the prosecution and the defense
and the public
for everyone to know what happened why
do you think the resistance continues in
iowa
as it does in other states i think
sometimes
um things that happened in you know the
blink of an eye
when you look at them afterward police
may think oh we didn't
exactly do the right thing here or we
could have done this better
um or they kind of hide behind a law
that that
is vague and so they may decline to
release it in cases when they're not
sure how they're gonna look
although we've found you know if it's
like a police officer helping deliver a
baby on the roadside we're going to get
that video
that's one they want to put out they'll
put it out on facebook or something
and so really bottom line if police have
complete control they're not really
willing
to show themselves in a bad light are
they yeah there's a lot of discretion to
the police chief or sheriff and
and some are more open than others and
so for the families seeking justice they
have to fight in court
spend money to do that lots of times
that is the
the only surefire way to get the video
if you're dealing with an agency that is
not as concerned with transparency
so the use of body cameras by police is
increasingly widespread
yes we found about 90 percent of the
agencies that responded
from the largest the smallest
departments in iowa are using them
but not so widespread is the requirement
that they make them public
in instances where the police may have
been accused of misconduct
correct so that needs to be changed from
your point of view
i would like to see it that we could you
know that that those would be part
declared part of the immediate facts and
circumstances of a case
and that those videos would be made
public and you know especially
um in cases where there's a question of
officer misconduct
um i think that video would really help
the public understand what happened
all right aaron jordan thank you so much
for being with us here tonight
thank you coming up next this week's
winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the decisions made
by the editors of mediate about fox
news's
bret bear you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan
abrams media empire aidan good to have
you here the first winner this week
bret baer of fox news why is he a winner
okay so brett bearer of fox news last
week uh
covered the matt gates story now that
may not sound like a big deal
um but fox news had been ignoring the
story uh
for days um the uh there was the initial
allegations uh that came out in a new
york times report about the justice
department
investigation into matt gates they were
looking into whether or not he had a
relationship with a 17 year old girl
and whether or not he uh was guilty of
uh or at least committed sex trafficking
uh fox news had tucker carlson interview
with matt gates that night
the next day they covered the story a
little bit and then they went radio
silent they stopped covering the matt
gates story and then
on thursday night when the new york
times reported
that the justice department
investigation was looking into
matt gates sexual relationships with
numerous women and whether or not he
paid them
for sex fox news was not covering the
story at all
and i actually published a story on
friday morning pointing that out
noting that msnbc and cnn were covering
this scandal about this uh
congressman from florida uh walt wall
and fox news hadn't mentioned it
um since uh they had covered uh his
initial interview on tucker carlson
uh which did not go very well for
neither the congressman or the fox news
host
um hours later bret baer covered it on
his fox news show special report
uh so we are giving bret bear some props
here uh for being the first show on fox
news to actually cover that story
um which is eminently newsworthy um as
well as being a sort of salacious story
that's perfect for table tunes
and it's a bit like uh dabbing with fame
praise for fox news though
elsewhere no real coverage
yeah you know since bret baer covered it
at 6 p.m
on uh on special report it's been
covered on other fox news shows
um so kudos to the shows that have
covered this story in the days 10th
um and i do think that there is deserved
props for for bret baer who who often
um has a good news mandate on his show
for what he covers
um the opinion shows uh every show in
prime time
uh fox news that has still not covered
this um as well as fox and friends which
the clients covered on friday morning
um those are the shows that i think
deserve some criticism for ignoring this
um simply because it is a scandal
involving a
republican congressman who praised
donald trump and he certainly stands out
as a straight shooter at fox news
this week's loser a rare stumble by 60
minutes
in a report about the governor of
florida by sharon alfonsey
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination in palm beach
what you're saying is right how is that
not pay to play that's a fake narrative
the criticism is that it's pay to play
governor it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not
so aidan where do you think 60 minutes
went wrong
so right so 60 minutes as you you noted
or suggested
is like the paragon of journalistic
integrity um their
their reports are incredibly buttoned up
this
report basically on the vaccination
rollout in florida
has been getting intense criticism i'll
just say the national review
editorial board referred to the segment
as an aspersion a slander a smear
of governor ron desantis in florida and
it's not just conservatives they're
calling out
uh 60 minutes for this uh segment
basically the suggestion of the segment
was that uh that the publix which was
given exclusive rights to the
distribution of
the chronovirus vaccine in certain
counties in florida had also donated a
hundred thousand dollars to governor
desantis's
uh gubernatorial campaign um and that
there was somehow a pay-per-place scheme
there
afoot now the criticism that the 60
minutes is getting rightfully
um is that government defense actually
explained in that clip you just saw
why it was that public scholars have
access to the vaccine it's because it
was the first
pharmacy that was ready for this it
exists throughout florida and is easily
accessible to floridians
it makes a lot of sense um that was not
included in the 60 minutes report and in
fact the
democratic mayor of palm beach county
criticized
uh 60 minutes and said that they had
intentionally left out
information that he thought uh
exonerated defenses in this story
um so it certainly looks like a
journalistic blunder from 60 minutes
here
and the question really is about the
editing and what they put in and what
they took out
next 30 seconds here aidan that's right
and uh there's if you see the side by
side of what uh 60 minutes kept in from
ron defense's comments there
they kept in the combative stuff where
he said that it's a fake narrative
they did not keep in his explanation of
what happened which is what
his critics are pointing out was sort of
a journalistic blunder
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for this week's winners and losers
in the media
and thanks to all of you for joining us
and finally a big thanks to our staff
at law and crime for getting us on the
air and off there
[Music]
[Applause]
you